[Musique]
il y a différentes axes et différentes
données qui nous permettent de mieux
comprendre la vie des Parisi de cette
époque en fait c'est les modes
d'inhumation donc c'est qu'elles ont été
les gestes au moment de l'inhumation
donc
comprendre pourquoi il y a des fausses
qui sont plus profondes pourquoi il y a
des regroupements de ces bulles qu'on a
l'impression que ça fait des grappes
donc c'est comprendre tous les gestes au
moment des inhumations et les rides
funéraires nous permet de mieux
comprendre la la
société des Parisiens on va pouvoir
faire et des études sur l'ADN grâce aux
ossements qu'on a pu retrouver on en
sera plus sur l'état sanitaire des
populations donc on s'approche avec une
petite série à une meilleure verre une
meilleure reconnaissance de la
population de Paris dans l'Antiquité
[Musique]
mettez énormément de
limites de la nécropole on a juste un
secteur le secteur présente différents
enclos et présente une densité
d'occupation pour l'être humain
importante donc ça montre qu'en fait de
compte ce quartier était occupé de
manière dense et cette nécropole était
nécropole importante
[Musique]